when Osiris Argentina
one of the most vibrant city
destinations in the world for three
million locals known as port Aeneas
this is home hello hello hello
che cosa fácil went again voila
a city where European sensibility meets
Latin American passion everyone who
comes to water sighted they should come
and watch follow three poor tenuous are
about to take you on a tour of their
city for them it's not so much about
seeing the sights as enjoying the
experiences when Asada's has to offer
this is the biggest street mural in the
world and this is the artist who did it
trami go king gala bueno acaba capo
Moacir at en sus años el mural let
Rotondo a lost robbery for Larios a loss
for Tina's alguna manera alfredo sega
tori is one of many celebrated street
artists if you use the city scape as
their canvas if you want to get a feel
for the social and cultural forces
shaping this city then the street art is
a good place to start see me do poor
cuestiones de la vida de pintura en
lugar des des gens de barrio carencia
beaucoup de siempre traje knesset a
matica Pico Serrano's este juego es una
manera de Sam are you Pogo l-drago
goggle app into Oren Pogo in Greece
lejano la historia del o distintos lugar
A's Gracia a via Hawaii is Tavo aloof
webelo fellow this less affluent
neighborhood or barrio as they're known
here is called Baracus and it's full of
colorful characters
ah God ah poor power
Jenny is in the horizontal cheeto a kind
Palermo nossek on seeing a target area
the mall you may not get a chance to
take a tour in Alfredo's colorful bus
street art tours are just starting to
emerge here they're a great opportunity
to understand this city and see some of
the sights
Yasu rebellion much of the imagery is
reflective of this city's social
political and economic struggles it's
also a celebration of its inhabitants
collective passions like horses no where
is this love affair more apparent than
at the annual Palermo polo tournament
held in the heart of the city in
November and December it might be called
the sport of kings but for the authentic
experience you don't have to be part of
the jet-set Pilar is the world capital
of polo and is just 40 minutes north of
the city
it keeps a certain glamour but it's not
like a super posh thing is more people
who love horses and life outdoors
santiago Tanoa is 31 he's one of
Argentina's top polo players and he
scheme that visitors see another side to
this sport you don't have to be a
moulting my year so mostly the people
who play are people from the countryside
or the farm you can go with your t-shirt
and everyone will welcome you today it's
a practice session but in the high
season between September and December
there are dozens of fixtures played
around here every day I think everyone
who comes to waterside is they should
come and watch follow because it is a
spectacle the best players in the world
are playing a sport where they go and 60
miles an hour in a 300 yard feel trying
to hit a little ball and a sport that
combines speed technique and courage
in this part of the world it's a sport
where high society meets hundreds of
years of Gaucho culture half of the big
out choice the horse they live and die
with the horses it's a big part of our
history a history that's coupled with
hospitality after the match
try an asado Argentina's national dish
where slabs of beef are cooked on the
fire in time-honored fashion well so
it's a big part of our culture and it's
a big part of any friendship ritual in
Argentina I think it's the best food we
have to offer to anyone who comes to our
dinner this is what's known as slow food
best experienced in the great outdoors
over several hours with a splash of
Malbec
back in the heart of the city lunchtime
is in full swing in la jolla CA one of
73 so-called ballets nor Tablas
establishments that have been enshrined
by the government as national treasures
sis parece que tiene que ver con queso
Sandra Akio por que o en parle no
synchro's un poco de del Barrio
barbra a guerra is a psychologist who's
lived in when aside as her whole life
Celia palledorous you know I'll give you
a candy bar sugar be instigator hey hey
hey Drita che cosa fácil cuenta que para
algo el en Vida Delmar do it's not just
the atmosphere that's a draw for Barbara
and her friends Thomas Lewis yamuna
picada poor tenia que bueno consignee a
lagoon OC hombres en at efficacy Kunis
quesos y carne con coca Paradiso phone
Saurabh Ravi escena Barrett Evo hace
classical nausea these are local bars
for local people and the perfect place
for visitors to experience a flavor of
this city creo que siento and adharma
Nemo's lager eggnog a vested interest
and airport Neos esta y particulary a--
por por el vin culo connoisseur gente
para vinculin SE y para expresar say Dom
Ian and Barbara should know as well as
being a psychologist she's also a
musician and performer and believes it's
street music that's the real expression
of this city's character for painting
practicals a multicast and Davila answer
como de la electricals only tremendous
you can find impromptu music on the
streets of san telmo district any day of
the week and while tangos the dance
invented here and most associated with
this city candomblé a is the beat that
barbara likes to perform vale encuentro
de la grappa Nia
encontrar en la cocina faster público a
poder trash metier mucho sentimientos
mutually de atras el Tambor the streets
of Buenos Aires have a lot to offer when
Outsiders coming and the work is
undergone in Argentina's seismic
economic crash of 2001 spawned a
thriving market culture and today Buenos
Aires remains a city renowned for its
bargains
it's the city's flea markets where
artist Alfredo spends much of his time
listo para compartir
bueno el mercado whoo yeah forum es un
lugar inspiration me periodicity la
gente daca guy muchas cosas que tienen
que con el recycler hey put price cut
price el mercado de La poule gas is one
of the biggest flea markets in South
America and a thriving hub of this
community
puede puede la luna de la crisis esto se
Paseos - veeram yo mo missouri
importance Aguero's a foreign Desiro
Hondo hace que la hora que es un lugar
AG en el mercado son Lindo lugar para
recommend are a loss to Rita's que venga
biragi miss a evo caminando with more
than 13,000 square meters of
back-to-back stalls the market offers an
astonishing range of items when a ver
que tenemos a cast a local DNA goes ah
muy interesante hay muchas cosas de
Vougeot knows a now digas moco Senado
diga porto area me today stays te cuento
es una brew hula tennozu novita agora
esta bueno ropa a Oh Emilio Cho siento a
gondola
on the other side of town the real music
is getting going
Barbara is joining friends at America
when aside as unique style of Carnival
this maka isn't Baracus but you're in
February there are more than 100 more
cos in district throughout the city poor
tenia tiene que ver con mucha
tradiciones que de de culturas immigrant
A's yes clock a 2d era Nunez carry on
see Steven Yeun amor de valor in de
Moura express our sincere haciendo vile
a lo que van a ver ciertas ruptura con
respecto el cuerpo que tienen que ver
con promper cadena saemmul our este a
los vamos
colorful and enthralling the morgue a
movement is also entwined with political
satire and dissent good solvent outlawed
in the late 70s and early 80s under
Argentina's dictatorship la palabra
poder communica que akka tambien
construe emos seguidilla in olv damos
chot see associa sadie arrow en nuestro
mise en la ciudad y CC at nom
the locals in palermo it's a very
different kind of vibe this is the
well-heeled part of town where santiago
and his girlfriend liked to party
the negative in bonus itis is pretty big
if you want bars you have and DJs that
comes from every part of the world but
if you're visiting and want to feel like
an insider you should try to access
Buenos Aires underground night scene
hidden behind secret doors and
passageways at the back of a restaurant
you need to know a password before you
can gain entry to this bar you see a
closed door and you open and it's an
amazing bar with all the things that you
could have never imagined
welcome to the Nicki Harrison speakeasy
prohibition-style bars like these are a
big part of the city's nightlife the
secret part started appearing in the
years 2000 when the country was pretty
broke
people started open bars behind closed
doors literally in Vanuatu secreta
reporter comida para mucho mucho mucho
time but the real secret of this bar is
the menu you could find the best
cocktails in the city and probably one
of the best in the world for those with
a little initiative the excess passwords
to places like this can be discovered by
asking around at Palermo's bars and
restaurants for people who come to win a
situs you have to find out where they
are the password I think they will live
an interesting experience for the
culturally curious this is a city
littered with hidden gems if only you
know where to find them